go ahead lewis  hey scotty uh before you came into the  league  um did you have a uh poster of brown in  your room like what did he mean to you  you know as a kid  say that again  uh what did lebron mean to you as a kid  before you got into the league  uh  i said really i was really a big kobe  fan uh  really  so it was really like rivals and stuff  like that but of course lebron done so  much for this game uh  of course the hall of famer uh  someone that's just so influential in  this game  that just pays paves the way for so many  people uh being big athletic like my  size being able to drill the ball do  multiple different things on the floor  so of course he was influential for a  lot of young kids like me